the following is a conversation with
Chris flattener currently he's a senior
director of Google working on several
projects including CPU GPU TPU
accelerators for tensorflow
swift for tensorflow and all kinds of
machine learning compiler magic going on
behind the scenes he's one of the top
experts in the world on compiler
technologies which means he deeply
understands the intricacies of how
hardware and software come together to
create efficient code he created the
LLVM compiler infrastructure project and
the clang compiler he led major
engineering efforts at Apple including
the creation of the Swift programming
language he also briefly spent time at
Tesla as vice president of auto pilot
software during the transition from
autopilot Hardware 1 to hardware 2 when
Tesla essentially started from scratch
to build an in-house software
infrastructure for autopilot I could
have easily talked to Chris for many
more hours compiling code down across
the levels abstraction is one of the
most fundamental and fascinating aspects
of what computers do and he is one of
the world experts in this process it's
rigorous science and it's messy
beautiful art this conversation is part
of the artificial intelligence podcast
if you enjoy it subscribe on youtube
itunes or simply connect with me on
twitter at Lex Friedman spelled Fri D
and now here's my conversation with
Chris Ladner what was the first program
you've ever written my first program
back and when was it I think I started
as a kid and my parents got a basic
programming book and so when I started
it was typing out programs from a book
and seeing how they worked and then
typing them in wrong and trying to
figure out why they were not working
right that kind of stuff so basic what
was the first language that you remember
yourself maybe falling in love with like
really connecting with I don't know I
mean I feel like I've learned a lot
along the way and each of them have a
different special thing about them so I
started in basic and then went like
gw-basic which was the thing back in the
DOS days and then
upgrade to QBasic and eventually quick
basic which are all slightly more fancy
versions of Microsoft basic made the
jump to Pascal and start doing machine
language programming and assembly in
Pasco which was really cool through
Pascal was amazing for its day
eventually going to C C++ and then kind
of did lots of other weird things I feel
like you took the dark path which is the
you could you could have gone Lisp yeah
you've got a higher-level sort of
functional philosophical hippy route
instead you went into like the dark arts
of the straight straight in the machine
straight to toys so started with basic
task element assembly and then wrote a
lot of assembly and why eventually I
eventually did small talk and other
things like that but that was not the
starting point but so what
what is this journey to see is that in
high school is that in college that was
in high school yeah so and then that was
it was really about trying to be able to
do more powerful things than what Pascal
could do and also to learn a different
world so he was really confusing me with
pointers and the syntax and everything
and it took a while but Pascal is much
more principled in various ways sees
more I mean it has its historical roots
but it's it's not as easy to learn with
pointers there's this memory management
thing that you have to become conscious
of is that the first time you start to
understand that there's resources that
you're supposed to manage well so you
have that in Pascal as well but in
Pascal these like the carrot instead of
the star and there's some small
differences like that but it's not about
pointer arithmetic and and and see it
you end up thinking about how things get
laid out in memory a lot more and so in
Pascal you have allocating and
deallocating and owning the the memory
but just the programs are simpler and
you don't have to well for example
Pascal has a string type and so you can
think about a string instead of an array
of characters which are consecutive in
memory so it's a little bit of a higher
level abstraction so let's get into it
let's talk about LLVM si Lang and
compilers
sure so can you tell me first what I
love the a messy laying our and how is
it that you find yourself the creator
and lead developer one of the most
powerful compiler optimization systems
than used today sure so I guess they're
different things so let's start with
what is a compiler
it's a is that a good place to start
what are the phases of a compiler where
the parts yeah what is it so what does
even a compiler are used for so the way
the way I look at this is you have a two
sided problem of you have humans that
need to write code and then you have
machines that need to run the program
that the human wrote and for lots of
reasons the humans don't want to be
writing in binary and want to think
about every piece of hardware and so at
the same time that you have lots of
humans you also have lots of kinds of
hardware and so compilers are the art of
allowing humans to think of the level of
abstraction that they want to think
about and then get that program get the
thing that they wrote to run on a
specific piece of hardware and the
interesting and exciting part of all
this is that there's now lots of
different kinds of hardware chips like
x86 and PowerPC and arm and things like
that but also high-performance
accelerators for machine learning and
other things like that or also just
different kinds of hardware GPUs these
are new kinds of hardware and at the
same time on the programming side of it
you have your basic UFC you have
JavaScript you have Python you so if you
have like lots of other languages that
are all trying to talk to the human in a
different way to make them more
expressive and capable and powerful and
so compilers are the thing that goes
from one to the other no and then from
the very beginning end to end and so you
go from what the human wrote and
programming languages end up being about
expressing intent not just for the
compiler and the hardware but the
programming languages job is really to
to capture an expression of what the
programmer wanted that then can be
maintained and adapted and evolved by
other humans as well as by the
interpreter by the compiler so so when
you look at this problem you have on one
hand humans which are complicated and
you have hardware which is complicated
until compilers typically work in
multiple phases and so the software
engineering challenge that you have here
is try to get maximum reuse out of the
the amount of code that you write
because this these compilers are very
complicated and so the way it typically
works out is that you have something
called a front-end or a parser that is
language specific and so you'll have a C
parser and that's what clang is or C++
or JavaScript or Python or whatever
that's the front-end then you'll have a
middle part which is often the optimizer
and then you'll have a late part which
is hardware specific and so compilers
end up there's many different layers
often but these three big groups are
very common in compilers and what LLVM
is trying to do is trying to standardize
that middle and last part and so one of
the cool things about LLVM is that there
are a lot of different languages that
compile through to it and so things like
swift but also julia rust clang for C
C++ objective-c like these are all very
different languages and they can all use
the same optimization infrastructure
which gets better performance and the
same code generation for structure for
hardware support and so LVM is really
that that layer that is common that all
these different specific compilers can
use and is that is it a standard like a
specification or is it literally an
implementation it's an implementation
and so it's I think there's a couple
different ways of looking at write
because it depends on what which angle
you're looking at it from
LVM ends up being a bunch of code okay
so it's a bunch of code that people
reuse and they build compilers with we
call it a compiler infrastructure
because it's kind of the underlying
platform that you build a concrete
compiler on top of but it's also a
community and the LVM community is
hundreds of people that all collaborate
and one of the most fascinating things
about LVM over the course of time is
that we've managed somehow to
successfully get harsh competitors in
the commercial space to collaborate on
shared infrastructure and so you have
Google and Apple you have AMD and Intel
you've Nvidia and
d on the graphics side you have prey and
everybody else doing these things and
like all these companies are
collaborating together to make that
shared infrastructure really really
great and they do this not other
businesses or heart but they do it
because it's in their commercial
interests of having really great
infrastructure that they can build on
top of and facing the reality that it's
so expensive that no one company even
the big companies no one company really
wants to implement it all themselves
expensive or difficult both that's a
great point because it's also about the
skill sets right and these the skill
sets are very hard hard to find how big
is the LLVM it always seems like with
open-source projects the kind you know
LLVM open source yes it's open source
it's about it's 19 years old now so it's
fairly old it seems like the magic often
happens within a very small circle of
people yes I'd like at least the early
birth and whatever yes so the LVM came
from a university project and so I was
at the University of Illinois and there
it was myself my advisor and then a team
of two or three research students in the
research group and we built many of the
core pieces initially I then graduated
went to Apple and Apple brought it to
the products first in the OpenGL
graphics stack but eventually to the C
compiler realm and eventually built
clang and eventually built Swift in
these things along the way building a
team of people that are really amazing
compiler engineers that helped build a
lot of that and so as it was gaining
momentum and as Apple was using it being
open source in public and encouraging
contribution many others for example at
Google came in and started contributing
and some cases Google effectively owns
clang now because it cares so much about
C++ and the evolution of that that
ecosystem and so it's a vesting a lot in
the C++ world and the tooling and things
like that
and so likewise Nvidia cares a lot about
CUDA and so CUDA uses clang and uses LVM
for for graphics and GPGPU and so when
you first started as a master's project
I guess
did you think is gonna go as far as it
went
were you uh crazy ambitious about it no
seems like a really difficult
undertaking a brave one yeah no it was
nothing like that so I mean my goal when
I went to University of Illinois was to
get in and out with the non thesis
masters in a year and get back to work
so I was not I was not planning to stay
for five years and and build this
massive infrastructure I got nerd sniped
into staying and a lot of it was because
Elvin was fun I was building cool stuff
than learning really interesting things
and facing will suffer engineering
challenges but also learning how to work
in a team and things like that I had
worked at many companies as interns
before that but it was really a
different a different thing to have a
team of people that were working
together and try and collaborate in
version control and it was it was just a
little bit different like I said I just
talked to Don Knuth and he believes that
2% of the world population have
something weird with their brain that
they're geeks they understand computers
to connect with computer he put it
exactly 2 percent okay so this specific
guy is very specific he says I can't
prove it but it's very empirical II
there is there something that attracts
you to the idea of optimizing code and
he seems like that's one of the biggest
coolest things about oh yeah that's one
of the major things it does so I got
into that because of a person actually
so when I was in my undergraduate I had
an advisor or a professor named Steve
Bechtel and he I went to this little
tiny private school we there were like
seven or nine people in my computer
science department students in my in my
class so it was a very tiny very very
small school it was a kind of a wart on
the side of the math department kind of
a thing at the time I think it's evolved
a lot in the many years since then but
but Steve egg Dahl was a compiler guy
and he was super passionate and he his
passion rubbed off on me and one of the
things I like about compilers is that
they're large complicated software
pieces and so one of the culminating
classes
is that many computer science
departments at least at the time did was
to say that you take algorithms and data
structures in all these core classes but
then the compilers class was one of the
last classes you take because it pulls
everything together and then you work on
one piece of code over the entire
semester and and so you keep building on
your own work which is really
interesting it's also very challenging
because in many classes if you don't get
a project done you just forget about it
and move on to the next one and get your
you know your B or whatever it is but
here you have to live with the decisions
you make and continue to reinvest in it
and I really like that and and so I did
a extra study project within the
following semester and he was just
really great and he was also a great
mentor in a lot of ways and so from from
him and from his advice he encouraged me
to go to graduate school I wasn't super
excited about going grad school I wanted
the master's degree but I didn't want to
be in academic and but like I said I
kind of got tricked into saying and was
having a lot of fun and I definitely do
not regret it what aspects of compilers
were the things you connected with so
LVM there's also the other part this is
really interesting if you're interested
in languages is parsing and you know
just analyzing like yeah analyzing
language breaking it out parsing so on
was that interesting to you were you
more engine optimization for me it was
more so I'm I'm not really a math person
I can do math I understand some bits of
it when I get into it but math is never
the thing that that attracted me and so
a lot of the parser part of the compiler
has a lot of good formal theories that
dawn for example knows quite well still
waiting for his book on that but but the
but I just like building a thing and and
seeing what it could do and exploring
and getting it to do more things and
then setting new goals and reaching for
them and and with in the case of
component in the case of LVM when I
start work on that my research advisor
that I was working for was a compiler
guy and so he and I specifically found
each other because we're both interested
in compilers and so I started working
with them and taking his class and a lot
of LLVM initially was it's fun
implementing all the standard algorithms
and all the all the things that pea
have been talking about and were
well-known and they were in the the
curricula for Advanced Studies and
compilers and so just being able to
build that was really fun and I was
learning a lot by instead of reading
about it just building and so I enjoyed
that
so he said compositor these complicated
systems can you even just with language
tried to describe you know how you turn
a C++ program yes into code like what
are the hard parts why is this hard so
I'll give you examples of the hard parts
Illinois so C++ is a very complicated
programming way which is something like
1400 pages in the spec so people as
possible as crazy complicated paas what
makes a language complicated in terms of
what's syntactically like us so it's
what they call syntax so the actual how
the character is arranged yes it's also
semantics how it behaves it's also in
the case of C++ there's a huge amount of
history C was supposed to build on top
of C you play that forward and then a
bunch of suboptimal in some cases
decisions were made and they compound
and then more and more and more things
keep getting added to C++ and it will
probably never stop but the language is
very complicated from that perspective
and so the interactions between
subsystems is very complicated there's
just a lot there and when you talk about
the front end one of the major
challenges which clang as a project the
the C C++ compiler that I built I and
many people built one of the challenges
we took on was we looked at GCC ok GCC
at the time was like a really good
industry standardized compiler that had
really consolidated a lot of the other
compilers in the world and was was a
standard but it wasn't really great for
research the design was very difficult
to work with and it was full of global
variables and other other things that
made it very difficult to reuse in ways
that it wasn't originally designed for
and so with claying one of the things
what we wanted to do is push forward on
better user interface so make error
messages that are just better than GCC's
and that that's actually hard because
you have to do a lot of bookkeeping in
an efficient way
today I'll do that we want to make
compile-time better and so compile-time
is about making it efficient which is
also really hard when you're keeping
track of extra information we wanted to
make new tools available so refactoring
tools and other analysis tools the the
GCC never supported also leveraging the
extra information we kept but enabling
those new classes the tools that then
get built into IDs and so that's been
one of the one of the areas that clang
has really helped push the world forward
in the tooling for C and C++ and things
like that but C++ and the front-end
piece is complicated and you have to
build syntax trees and you have to check
every rule in the spec and you have to
turn that back into an error message to
the humor humor that the human can
understand when they do something wrong
but then you start doing the what's
called lowering so going from C++ in the
way that it represents code down to the
machine and when you do that there's
many different phases you go through
often there are I think LLVM something
like 150 different what are called
passes in the compiler that the code
passed passes through and these get
organized in very complicated ways which
affect the generated code in performance
and compile time and many of the things
what are they passing through so after
you do the clang parsing what's what's
the graph what does it look like what's
the data structure here yeah so in in
the parser it's usually a tree and it's
called an abstract syntax tree and so
the idea is you you have a node for the
plus that the human wrote in their code
or the function call you'll have a node
for call with the function that they
call and the arguments they pass things
like that this then gets lowered into
what's called an intermediate
representation and intermediate
representations are like LVM has one and
there it's a it's what's called a
control flow graph and so you represent
each operation in the program as a very
simple like this is gonna add two
numbers this is gonna multiply two
things maybe we'll do a call but then
they get put in what are called blocks
and so you get blocks of these straight
line operations or instead of being
nested like in a tree it's straight line
operation
and so there's a sequence and ordering
to these operations and then in the
block we're outside the block that's
within the block and so it's a straight
line sequence of operations within the
block and then you have branches like
conditional branches between blocks and
so when you write a loop for example in
a syntax tree you would have a four node
like for a for statement and I see like
language you'd out a four node and you
have a pointer to the expression for the
initializer a pointer to the expression
for the increment a pointer to the
expression for the comparison a pointer
to the body okay and these are all
nested underneath it in a control flow
graph you get a block for the code that
runs before the loop so the initializer
code then you have a block for the body
of the loop and so the the body of the
loop code goes in there but also they
increment and other things like that and
then you have a branch that goes back to
the top and a comparison and branch that
goes out and so it's more of a assembly
level kind of representation but the
nice thing about this level of
representation is it's much more
language independent and so there's lots
of different kinds of languages with
different kinds of you know JavaScript
has a lot of different ideas of what is
false for example and all that can stay
in the front end but then that middle
part can be shared across all those how
close is that intermediate
representation to ten yuan that works
for example is they are they because
everything described as a kind of neural
network graph right yeah that's all we
need a neighbor's or what they're
they're quite different in details but
they're very similar and idea so one of
the things that normal networks do is
they learn representations for data at
different levels of abstraction right
and then they transform those through
layers right so the compiler does very
similar things but one of the things the
compiler does is it has relatively few
different representations or a neural
network often as you get deeper for
example you get many different
representations in each you know layer
or set of ops is transforming between
these different representations and
compiler often you get one
representation and they do many
transformations to it and these
transformations are often applied
iteratively
and for programmers there's familiar
types of things for example trying to
find expressions inside of a loop and
pulling them out of a loop so if they
execute four times or a fine
redundant computation or find constant
folding or other simplifications turning
you know 2 times X into X shift left by
one and and things like this or all all
all the examples of the things that
happen but compilers end up getting a
lot of theorem proving and other kinds
of algorithms that try to find
higher-level properties of the program
that then can be used by the optimizer
cool so what's like the biggest bang for
the buck with optimization what's there
yeah
well no not even today at the very
beginning the 80s I don't know but yeah
so for the 80s a lot of it was things
like register allocation so the idea of
in in a modern like a microprocessor
what you'll end up having is you're
having memory which is relatively slow
and then you have registers relatively
fast but registers you don't have very
many of them ok and so when you're
writing a bunch of code you're just
saying like compute this put it in
temporary variable compute those compute
this compute this put in temporary well
I have a loop I have some other stuff
going on
well now you're running on an x86 like a
desktop PC or something well it only has
in some cases some modes eight registers
right and so now the compiler has to
choose what values get put in what
registers at what points in the program
and this is actually a really big deal
so if you think about you have a loop
and then an inner loop to execute
millions of times maybe if you're doing
loads and stores inside that loop then
it's gonna be really slow but if you can
somehow fit all the values inside that
loop and registers now it's really fast
and so getting that right requires a lot
of work because there's many different
ways to do that and often what the
compiler ends up doing is it ends up
thinking about things in a different
representation than what the human wrote
all right you wrote into X well the
compiler thinks about that as four
different values each which have
different lifetimes across the function
that it's in and each of those could be
put in a register or memory or different
memory or maybe in some parts of the
code recomputed instead of stored and
reloaded and there are many of these
different kinds of techniques that can
be used so it's adding almost like a
time-dimension - it's trying to trying
to optimize across time so considering
when when you're programming you're not
thinking and yeah absolutely
and so the the RISC era made thing this
so so RISC chips Ras see the the risks
risk chips as opposed to sisk chips the
risk chips made things more complicated
for the compiler because what they ended
up doing is ending up adding pipelines
to the processor where the processor can
do more than one thing at a time but
this means that the order of operations
matters a lot and so one of the
classical compiler techniques that you
use is called scheduling and so moving
the instructions around so that the
processor can act like keep its
pipelines full instead of stalling and
getting blocked and so there's a lot of
things like that that are kind of bread
and butter a compiler techniques have
been studied a lot over the course of
decades now but the engineering side of
making them real is also still quite
hard and you talk about machine learning
this is this is a huge opportunity for
machine learning because many of these
algorithms are full of these like hokey
hand-rolled heuristics which work well
on specific benchmarks we don't
generalize and full of magic numbers and
you know I hear there's some techniques
that are good at handling that so what
would be the if you were to apply
machine learning to this what's the
thing you try to optimize is it
ultimately the running time you can pick
your metric and there's there's running
time there's memory use there's there's
lots of different things that you can
optimize for code code size is another
one that some people care about in the
embedded space is this like the thinking
into the future or somebody actually
been crazy enough to try to have machine
learning based parameter tuning for
optimization of compilers so this is
something that is I would say research
right now there are a lot of research
systems that have been applying search
in various forums and using
reinforcement learning is one form but
also brute force search has been tried
for a quite a while and usually these
are in small small problem spaces so
find the optimal way to code generate a
matrix multiply for a GPU write
something like that where we say there
there's a lot of
design space of do you unroll uppsala do
you execute multiple things in parallel
and there's many different confounding
factors here because graphics cards have
different numbers of threads and
registers and execution ports and memory
bandwidth and many different constraints
to interact in nonlinear ways and so
search is very powerful for that and it
gets used in in certain ways but it's
not very structured this is something
that we need we as an industry need to
fix these set ATS but like so have there
been like big jumps and improvement and
optimization yeah yeah yes since then
what's yeah so so it's largely been
driven by hardware so hartwell hardware
and software so in the mid-90s Java
totally changed the world right and and
I'm still amazed by how much change was
introduced by the way or in a good way
so like reflecting back Java introduced
things like it all at once introduced
things like JIT compilation
none of these were novel but it pulled
it together and made it mainstream and
and made people invest in it JIT
compilation garbage collection portable
code safe code say like memory safe code
like a very dynamic dispatch execution
model like many of these things which
had been done in research systems and
had been done in small ways and various
places really came to the forefront
really changed how things worked and
therefore changed the way people thought
about the problem javascript was another
major world change based on the way it
works but also on the hardware side of
things multi-core and vector
instructions really change the problem
space and are very they don't remove any
of the problems that composers faced in
the past but they they add new kinds of
problems of how do you find enough work
to keep a four-wide vector busy right or
if you're doing a matrix multiplication
how do you do different columns out of
that matrix in at the same time and how
do you maximally utilize the the
arithmetic compute that one core has and
then how do you take it to multiple
cores and how did the whole virtual
machine thing change the compilation
pipeline yeah so so what what the java
virtual machine does
is it splits just like I've talked about
before where you have a front-end that
parses the code and then you have an
intermediate representation that gets
transformed what Java did was they said
we will parse the code and then compile
to what's known as Java bytecode and
that bytecode is now a portable code
representation that is industry-standard
and locked down and can't change and
then the the back part of the compiler
the the does optimization and code
generation can now be built by different
vendors okay and Java bytecode can be
shipped around across the wire its
memory safe and relatively trusted and
because of that it can run in the
browser and that's why it runs in the
browser yeah right and so that way you
can be in you know again back in the day
you would write a Java applet and you
use as a little as a web developer you'd
build this mini app that run a web page
well a user of that is running a web
browser on their computer you download
that that Java bytecode which can be
trusted and then you do all the compiler
stuff on your machine so that you know
that you trust that that was that a good
idea a bad idea it's great idea I mean
it's great idea for certain problems and
I'm very much believe for the
technologies itself neither good nor bad
it's how you apply it you know this
would be a very very bad thing for very
low levels of the software stack but but
in terms of solving some of these
software portability and transparency
your portability problems I think it's
been really good now Java ultimately
didn't win out on the desktop and like
there are good reasons for that but it's
been very successful on servers and in
many places it's been a very successful
thing over over decades so what has been
ll VMs and ceilings improvements in
optimization that throughout its history
what are some moments we get set back
I'm really proud of what's been
accomplished yeah I think that the
interesting thing about LLVM is not the
innovations in compiler research it has
very good implementations of various
important algorithms no doubt and and a
lot of really smart people have worked
on it but I think that the thing was
most profound about LLVM is that through
standardization it made things possible
too
otherwise wouldn't have happened okay
and so interesting things that have
happened with LVM for example sony has
picked up lv m and used it to do all the
graphics compilation in their movie
production pipeline and so now they're
able to have better special effects
because of LVN that's kind of cool
that's not what it was designed for
right but that's that's the sign of good
infrastructure when it can be used in
ways it was never designed for because
it has good layering and software
engineering and it's composable and
things like that just where as you said
it differs from GCC yes GCC is also
great in various ways but it's not as
good as a infrastructure technology it's
it's you know it's really a C compiler
or it's or it's a fortunate compiler
it's not it's not infrastructure in the
same way is it now you can tell I don't
know what I'm talking about because I'm
sick eep saying si Lang you can you
could always tell when a person is close
by the way pronounce something I'm I
don't think have I ever used Clank
entirely possible have you well so
you've used code it's generated probably
so clang is an Alabama used to compile
all the apps on the iPhone effectively
and the OS is it compiles Google's
production server applications let's use
to build my GameCube games and
PlayStation 4 and things like that I was
a user I have but just everything I've
done that I experienced for Linux has
been I believe always GCC yeah I think
Linux still defaults to GCC and is there
a reason for that there's a big it's a
combination of technical and social
reasons many GC likes developers do you
do use clang but the distributions for
lots of reasons
use GCC historically and they've not
switched yeah that and it's just
anecdotally online it seems that LLVM
has either reached the level GCC or
superseded on different features or
whatever the way I would say it is that
there was there so close it doesn't
matter yeah exactly like there's a
slightly better in some way slightly
worse than otherwise but it doesn't
actually really matter anymore
that level so in terms of optimization
breakthroughs it's just been solid
incremental work yeah yeah
which which is which describes a lot of
compilers there are the hard thing about
compilers in my experience is the
engineering the software engineering
making it so that you can have hundreds
of people collaborating on really
detailed low-level work and scaling that
and that's that's really hard and that's
one of the things I think Alabama's done
well and that kind of goes back to the
original design goals with it to be
modular and things like that and
incidentally I don't want to take all
the credit for this right I mean some of
the the best parts about LLVM is that it
was designed to be modular and when I
started I would write for example a
register allocator and then some a much
smarter than me would come in and pull
it out and replace it with something
else that they would come up with and
because it's modular they were able to
do that and that's one of the challenges
with what GCC for example is replacing
subsystems is incredibly difficult it
can be done but it wasn't designed for
that and that's one of the reasons the
LVM has been very successful in the
research world as well but in the in the
community sense Widow van rossum right
from Python just retired from what is it
benevolent dictator for life right so in
managing this community of brilliant
compiler folks is there that did it at
for a time at least following you to
approve things oh yeah so I mean I still
have something like an order of
magnitude more patches in LVM than
anybody else and many of those I wrote
myself but he's still right I mean you
still he's still close to the two though
I don't know what the expression is to
the metal you still write code yes
alright good not as much as I was able
to in grad school but that's important
part of my identity but the way the LLVM
has worked over time is that when I was
a grad student I could do all the work
and steer everything and review every
patch and make sure everything was done
exactly the way my opinionated sense
felt like it should be done and that was
fine but I think scale you can't do that
right and so what ends
happening as LVM has a hierarchical
system of what's called code owners
these code owners are given the
responsibility not to do all the work
not necessarily to review all the
patches but to make sure that the
patches do get reviewed and make sure
that the right things happening
architectural e in their area and so
what you'll see is you'll see that for
example hardware manufacturers end up
owning the the the hardware specific
parts of their their their hardware
that's very common leaders in the
community that have done really good
work naturally become the de facto owner
of something and then usually somebody
else's like how about we make them the
official code owner and then and then
we'll have somebody to make sure the
whole patch does get reviewed in a
timely manner and then everybody's like
yes that's obvious and then it happens
right and usually this is a very organic
thing which is great and so I'm
nominally the top of that stack still
but I don't spend a lot of time
reviewing patches what I do is I help
negotiate a lot of the the technical
disagreements that end up happening and
making sure that the community as a
whole makes progress and is moving in
the right direction and and doing that
so we also started a non-profit and six
years ago seven years ago it's times
gone away and the nonprofit the the LVM
foundation nonprofit helps oversee all
the business sides of things and make
sure that the events that the Elven
community has are funded and set up and
run correctly and stuff like that
but the foundation is very much stays
out of the technical side of where where
the project was going right sounds like
a lot of it is just organic just yeah
well and this is Alabama is almost
twenty years old which is hard to
believe somebody point out to me
recently that LVM is now older than GCC
was when Olivia started right so time
has a way of getting away from you but
the good thing about that is it has a
really robust
really amazing community of people that
are in their professional lives spread
across lots of different companies but
it's a it's a community of people that
are interested in similar kinds of
problems and have been working together
effectively for years and have a lot of
trust and respect for each other and
even if they don't always agree that you
know we're
we'll find a path forward so then in a
slightly different flavor of effort you
started at Apple in 2005 with the task
of making I guess LLVM production ready
and then eventually 2013 through 2017
leading the entire developer tools
department we were talking about LLVM
Xcode Objective C to Swift so in a quick
overview of your time there what were
the challenges first of all leading such
a huge group of developers what was the
big motivator dream mission behind
creating Swift the early birth of it's
from objective-c and so on and Xcode
well yeah so these are different
questions yeah I know what about the
other stuff I'll stay I'll stay on the
technical side then we could talk about
the big team pieces yeah that's okay
sure so he has to really oversimplify
many years of hard work via most started
joined Apple became a thing we became
successful and became deployed but then
there was a question about how how do we
actually purse the source code so LVM is
that back part the optimizer and the
code generator and Alvin was really good
for Apple as it went through a couple of
hundred transitions I joined right at
the time of the Intel transition for
example and 64-bit transitions and then
the transition to almost the iPhone and
so LVM was very useful for some of these
kinds of things but at the same time
there's a lot of questions around
developer experience and so if you're a
programmer pounding out at the time of
objective-c code the error message you
get the compile time the turnaround
cycle the the tooling and the IDE were
not great we're not as good as it could
be and so you know as as I occasionally
do I'm like well okay how hard is it to
write a C compiler and so I I'm not
gonna commit to anybody I'm not gonna
tell anybody I'm just gonna just do it
on nice and weekends and start working
on it and then you know I built up in C
there's a thing called the preprocessor
which people don't like but it's
actually really hard and complicated and
includes a bunch of really weird things
like try graphs and other stuff like
that that are they're really nasty and
it's the crux of a bunch of the perform
issues in the compiler and I'm started
working on the parser and kind of got to
the point where I'm like ah you know
what we could actually do this this
everybody saying that this is impossible
to do but it's actually just hard it's
not impossible and eventually told my
manager about it and he's like oh wow
this is great we do need to solve this
problem oh this is great we can like get
you one other person to work with you on
this you know and slowly a team is
formed and it starts taking off and c++
for example huge complicated language
people always assume that it's
impossible to implement and it's very
nearly impossible but it's just really
really hard and the way to get there is
to build it one piece at a time
incrementally and and there that was
only possible because we were lucky to
hire some really exceptional engineers
that that knew various parts of it very
well and and could do great things
Swift was kind of a similar thing so
Swift came from we were just finishing
off the first version of C++ support in
M clang and C++ is a very formidable and
very important language but it's also
ugly in lots of ways and you can't
influence C++ without thinking there has
to be a better thing right and so I
started working on Swift again with no
hope or ambition that would go anywhere
just uh let's see what could be done
let's play around with this thing it was
you know me in my spare time not telling
anybody about it kind of a thing and it
made some good progress I'm like
actually it would make sense to do this
at the same time I started talking with
the senior VP of software at the time a
guy named Burt Ron stole a and Burt Ron
was very encouraging he was like well
you know let's let's have fun let's talk
about this and he was a little bit of a
language guy and so he helped guide some
of the the early work and encouraged me
and like got things off the ground and
eventually I've told other to like my
manager and told other people and and it
started making progress the the
complicating thing was Swift was that
the idea of doing a new language is not
obvious to anybody including myself
and the tone at the time was that the
iPhone was successful because of
objective-c right Oh interesting in a
practice site of or just great because
it and and you have to understand that
at the time
Apple was hiring software people that
loved Objective C right and it wasn't
that they came despite Objective C they
loved Objective C and that's why they
got hired and so you had a software team
that the leadership and in many cases
went all the way back to next where
Objective C really became real and so
they quote-unquote grew up writing
Objective C and many of the individual
engineers all were hired because they
loved Objective C and so this notion of
okay let's do new language was kind of
heretical in many ways right meanwhile
my sense was that the outside community
wasn't really in love with Objective C
some people were and some of the most
outspoken people were but other people
were hitting challenges because it has
very sharp corners and it's difficult to
learn and so one of the challenges of
making Swift happen that was totally
non-technical is the the social part of
what do we do like if we do a new
language which at Apple many things
happen that don't ship right so if we if
we ship it what what what is the metrics
of success why would we do this why
wouldn't we make Objective C better if
object C has problems let's file off
those rough corners and edges and one of
the major things that became the reason
to do this was this notion of safety
memory safety and the way Objective C
works is that a lot of the object system
and everything else is built on top of
pointers and C Objective C is an
extension on top of C and so pointers
are unsafe and if you get rid of the
pointers it's not Objective C anymore
and so fundamentally that was an issue
that you could not fix safety or memory
safety without fundamentally changing
the language and so once we got through
that part of the mental process and the
thought process it became a design
process of saying okay well if we're
gonna do something new what what is good
like how do we think about this and what
do we like and what are we looking for
and that that was a very different phase
of it so well what are some design
choices early on and Swift like we're
talking about braces are you making a
type language or not all those kinds of
things yeah so some of those were
obvious given the context so a types
language for example objective sees a
typed language and going with an untyped
language wasn't really seriously
considered we wanted we want the
performance and we wanted refactoring
tools and other things like that to go
with type languages quick dumb question
yeah was it obvious
I think it would be a dumb question but
was it obvious that the language has to
be a compiled language not and yes
that's not a dumb question earlier I
think late 90s Apple is seriously
considered moving its development
experience to Java but this was started
in 2010 which was several years after
the iPhone it was when the iPhone was
definitely on an upward trajectory and
the iPhone was still extremely and is
still a bit memory constrained right and
so being able to compile the code and
then ship it and then have having
standalone code that is not JIT compiled
was is a very big deal and it's very
much part of the apple value system now
javascript is also a thing right I mean
it's not it's not that this is exclusive
and technologies are good depending on
how they're applied right but in the
design of Swift saying like how can we
make Objective C better right Objective
C is statically compiled and that was
the contiguous natural thing to do just
skip ahead a little bit now go right
back just just as a question as you
think about today in 2019 yeah in your
work at Google if tons of phone so on is
again compilations static compilation
the right there's still the right thing
yes so the the funny thing after working
on compilers for a really long time is
that and one of this is one of the
things that LVM has helped with is that
I don't look as comp compilations being
static or dynamic or interpreted or not
this is a spectrum okay and one of the
cool things about Swift is that Swift is
not just statically compiled
it's actually dynamically compiled as
well and it can also be interpreted that
nobody's actually done that and so what
what ends up happening when you use
Swift in a workbook for example in
Calabria and Jupiter is it's actually
dynamically compiling the statements as
you execute them and so let's gets back
to the software engineering problems
right where if you layer the stack
properly you can actually completely
change how and when things get compiled
because you have the right abstractions
there and so the way that a collab
workbook
works with Swift is that we start typing
into it it creates a process a UNIX
process and then each line of code you
type in it compiles it through the Swift
compiler there's the front end part and
then sends it through the optimizer JIT
compiles machine code and then injects
it into that process and so as you're
typing new stuff it's putting it's like
squirting a new code and overriding and
replacing an updating code in place and
the fact that it can do this is not an
accident like Swift was designed for
this but it's an important part of how
the language was set up and how it's
layered and and this is a non-obvious
piece and one of the things with Swift
that was for me a very strong design
point is to make it so that you can
learn it very quickly and so from a
language design perspective the thing
that I always come back to is this UI
principle of progressive disclosure of
complexity and so in Swift you can start
by saying print quote hello world quote
right and there's no /n just like Python
one line of code no main no no header
files no header files no public static
class void blah blah blah string like
Java has right so one line of code right
and you can teach that and it works
great they can say well let's introduce
variables and so you can declare a
variable with far so VAR x equals four
what is a variable you can use xx plus
one this is what it means then you can
say we'll have a control flow well this
is what an if statement is this is what
a for statement is this is what a while
statement is then you can say let's
introduce functions right and and many
languages like Python have had this this
kind of notion of let's introduce small
things and they can add complex
then you can introduce classes and then
you can add generics I'm against the
Swift and then you can in modules and
build out in terms of the things that
you're expressing but this is not very
typical for compiled languages and so
this was a very strong design point and
one of the reasons that Swift in general
is designed with this factoring of
complexity in mind so that the language
can express powerful things you can
write firmware in Swift if you want to
but it has a very high-level feel which
is really this perfect blend because
often you have very advanced library
writers that want to be able to use the
the nitty-gritty details but then other
people just want to use the libraries
and work at a higher abstraction level
it's kind of cool that I saw that you
can just enter a probability I don't
think I pronounced that word enough but
you can just drag in Python it's just a
string you can import like I saw this in
the demo yeah I'm pointing out but like
how do you make that happen
yeah what's what's up yeah say is that
as easy as it looks
or is it yes that's not that's not a
stage magic hack or anything like that
then I I don't mean from the user
perspective I mean from the
implementation perspective to make it
happen
so it's it's easy once all the pieces
are in place the way it works so if you
think about a dynamically typed language
like Python right you can think about it
as in two different ways you can say it
has no types right which is what most
people would say or you can say it has
one type right and you could say has one
type and it's like the Python object
mm-hmm and the Python object gets passed
around and because there's only one type
its implicit okay and so what happens
with Swift and Python talking to each
other Swift has lots of types right has
a raise and it has strings and all like
classes and that kind of stuff but it
now has a Python object type right so
there is one Python object type and so
when you say import numpy what you get
is a Python object which is the numpy
module then you say NPRA it says okay
hey hey Python object I have no idea
what you are give me your array member
right okay cool it just it just uses
dynamic stuff talks to the Python
interpreter and says hey Python what's
the daughter a member in the
that Python object it gives you back
another Python object and now you say
parentheses for the call and the
arguments are gonna pass and so then it
says hey a Python object that is the
result of NPR a call with these
arguments right again calling into the
Python interpreter to do that work and
so right now this is all really simple
and if you if you dive into the code
what you'll see is that the the Python
module and Swift is something like
twelve hundred lines of code or
something is written in pure Swift it's
super simple and it's and it's built on
top of the c interoperability because
just talks to the Python interpreter but
making that possible required us to add
two major language features to Swift to
be able to express these dynamic calls
and the dynamic member lookups and so
what we've done over the last year is
we've proposed implement standardized
and contributed new language features to
the Swift language in order to make it
so it is really trivial right and this
is one of the things about Swift that is
critical to this but for tens flow work
which is that we can actually add new
language features and the bar for adding
those is high but it's it's what makes
it possible so you know Google doing
incredible work on several things
including tensorflow
the test flow 2.0 or whatever leading up
to 2.0 has by default in 2.0 has eager
execution in yet in order to make code
optimized for GPU or TP or some of these
systems computation needs to be
converted to a graph so what's that
process like what are the challenges
there yeah so I I'm tangentially
involved in this but the the way that it
works with autograph is that
you mark your your function with the
decorator and when Python calls that
that decorator is invoked and then it
says before I call this function you can
transform it and so the way autograph
works is as far as I understand as it
actually uses the Python parser to go
parse that turn into a syntax tree and
now apply compiler techniques to again
transform this down into tensor
photographs and so it you can think of
it as saying hey I have an if statement
I'm going to create an if node in the
graph
like you say TF conned you have a
multiply well I'll turn that into
multiply node in the graph and that
becomes the street transformation so
word is the Swift for tensor for come in
which is you know parallels you know for
one swift is a interface like Python is
an interface test flow but it seems like
there's a lot more going on in just a
different language interface there's
optimization methodology yeah so so the
tensor float world has a couple of
different what I'd call front-end
technologies and so Swift and Python and
go and rust and Julia and all these
things share the tensor flow graphs and
all the runtime and everything that's
later again and so vertex flow is merely
another front end for tensor flow I'm
just like any of these other systems are
there's a major difference between I
would say three camps of technologies
here there's Python which is a special
case because the vast majority of the
community efforts go into the Python
interface and python has its own
approaches for automatic differentiation
it has its own api's and all this kind
of stuff
there's Swift which I'll talk about in a
second and then there's kind of
everything else and so the everything
else are effectively language bindings
so they they call into the tense flow
runtime but they're not they usually
don't have automatic differentiation or
they usually don't provide anything
other than API is that call the C API is
intensive flow and so they're kind of
wrappers for that Swift is really kind
of special and it's a very different
approach Swift 4/10 below that is is a
very different approach because there
we're saying let's look at all the
problems that need to be solved in the
fullest
of the tensorflow compilation process if
you think about it that way because
tensorflow is fundamentally a compiler
it takes models and then it makes them
go faster on hardware that's what a
compiler does and it has a front end it
has an optimizer and it has many
backends and so if you think about it
the right way
or in in if you look at it in a
particular way like it is a compiler
okay and and so Swift is merely another
front-end but it's saying in the the
design principle is saying let's look at
all the problems that we face as machine
learning practitioners and what is the
best possible way we can do that given
the fact that we can change literally
anything in this entire stack and python
for example where the vast majority of
the engineering and an effort has gone
into its constrained by being the best
possible thing you can do with the
Python library like there are no Python
language features that are added because
of machine learning that I'm aware of
they added a matrix multiplication
operator with that but that's as close
as you get and so with Swift you can you
it's hard but you can add language
features to the language and there's a
community process for that and so we
look at these things and say well what
is the right division of labor between
the human programmer and the compiler
and Swift has a number of things that
shift that balance so because it's a
because it has a type system for example
it makes certain things possible for
analysis of the code and the compiler
can automatically build graphs for you
without you thinking about them like
that's that's a big deal for a
programmer you just get free performance
you get clustering infusion and
optimization and things like that
without you as a programmer having to
manually do it because the compiler can
do it for you automatic to frenchie
ation there's another big deal and it's
I think one of the key contributions of
the Swift for tensorflow project is that
there's this entire body of work on
automatic differentiation that dates
back to the Fortran days people doing a
tremendous amount of numerical computing
and Fortran used to write these what
they call source-to-source translators
where you where you take a bunch of code
shove it into a mini compiler and push
out more Fortran code but it would
generate the backwards passes for your
functions for you the derivatives and so
in that work in the 70s a true master of
optimizations a tremendous number of
techniques for fixing numerical
instability and other other kinds of
problems were developed but they're very
difficult to port into a world where in
eager execution you get an opt by op at
a time like you need to be able to look
at an entire function and be able to
reason about what's going on and so when
you have a language integrated automatic
differentiation which is one of the
things that the Swift project is
focusing on you can open open all these
techniques and reuse them and in
familiar ways but the language
integration piece has a bunch of design
room in it and it's also complicated the
other piece of the puzzle here that's
kind of interesting is TP use at Google
yes so you know we're in a new world
with deep learning it's constantly
changing and I imagine without
disclosing anything I imagine you know
you're still innovating on the TP you
front - indeed so how much sort of
interplay xur between software and
hardware in trying to figure out how to
gather move towards at an optimal
solution there's an incredible amount so
our third generation of TP use which are
now 100 petaflop syn a very large liquid
cooled box in a virtual box with no
cover
and as you might imagine we're not out
of ideas yet the the great thing about
TP use is that they're a perfect example
of hardware/software co.design and so
it's a bet it's about saying what
hardware do we build to solve certain
classes of machine learning problems
well the algorithms are changing like
the hardware it takes you know some
cases years to produce right and so you
have to make bets and decide what is
going to happen and so and what is the
best way to spend the transistors to get
the maximum you know performance per
watt or area per cost or like whatever
it is that you're optimizing for and so
one of the amazing things about TP use
is this numeric format called b-flat 16b
float16 is a compressed 16-bit
floating-point format but it puts the
bits in different places in numeric
terms it has a smaller mantissa and a
larger exponent that means that it's
less precise but it can represent larger
ranges of values which in the machine
learning context is really important and
useful because sometimes you have very
small gradients you want to accumulate
and very very small numbers that are
important to to move things as you're
learning but sometimes you have very
large magnitude numbers as well and be
float16 is not as precise the mantissa
is small but it turns out the machine
learning algorithms actually want to
generalize and so there's you know
theories that this actually increases
generate the ability for the network to
generalize across data sets and
regardless of whether it's good or bad
is much cheaper at the hardware level to
implement because the area and time of a
multiplier is N squared in the number of
bits in the mantissa but it's linear
with size of the exponent connected to
solar big deal efforts here both on the
hardware and the software side yeah and
so that was a breakthrough coming from
the research side and people working on
optimizing network transport of weights
across a network originally and trying
to find ways to compress that but then
it got burned into silicon and it's a
key part of what makes CPU performance
so amazing and and and great TPS have
many different aspects of the
important but the the co.design between
the low-level compiler bits and the
software bits and the algorithms is all
super important and it's a this amazing
try factor that only Google do yeah
that's super exciting so can you tell me
about MLI our project previously this
the secretive one yeah so EMA lair is a
project that we announced at a compiler
conference three weeks ago or something
at the compilers for machine learning
conference basically if again if you
look at tensorflow as a compiler stack
it has a number of compiler algorithms
within it it also has a number of
compilers that get embedded into it and
they're made by different vendors for
example Google has xla which is a great
compiler system NVIDIA has tensor RT
Intel has n graph there's a number of
these different compiler systems and
they're very hardware specific and
they're trying to solve different parts
of the problems but they're all kind of
similar in a sense of they want to
integrate with tensorflow no test flow
has an optimizer and it has these
different code generation technologies
built in the idea of NLR is to build a
common infrastructure to support all
these different subsystems and initially
it's to be able to make it so that they
all plug in together and they can share
a lot more code and can be reusable but
over time we hope that the industry will
start collaborating and sharing code and
instead of reinventing the same things
over and over again that we can actually
foster some of that that you know
working together to solve common problem
energy that has been useful in the
compiler field before beyond that mor is
some people have joked that it's kind of
LVM to it learns a lot about what LVM
has been good and what LVM has done
wrong and it's a chance to fix that and
also there are challenges in the LLVM
ecosystem as well where LVM is very good
at the thing was designed to do but you
know 20 years later the world has
changed and people are trying to solve
higher-level problems and we need we
need some new technology and what's the
future of open source in this context
very soon so it is not yet open source
but it will be hopefully you still
believe in the value of open source in
kazakh oh yeah absolutely and I
that the tensorflow community at large
fully believes an open-source so I mean
that's there is a difference between
Apple where you were previously in
Google now in spirit and culture and I
would say the open sourcing intensive
floor was a seminal moment in the
history of software because here's this
large company releasing a very large
code base as the open sourcing what are
your thoughts on that
I'll happy or not were you to see that
kind of degree of open sourcing so
between the two I prefer the Google
approach if that's what you're saying
the Apple approach makes sense given the
historical context that Apple came from
but that's been 35 years ago and I think
the Apple is definitely adapting and the
way I look at it is that there's
different kinds of concerns in the space
right it is very rational for a business
to to care about making money that
fundamentally is what a business is
about right but I think it's also
incredibly realistic to say it's not
your string library that's the thing
that's going to make you money it's
going to be the amazing UI product
differentiating features and other
things like that that you built on top
of your string library and so keeping
your string library proprietary and
secret and things like that isn't maybe
not the the important thing anymore
right or before platforms were different
right and even 15 years ago things were
a little bit different but the world is
changing so Google strikes very good
balance I think and I think the
tensorflow being open source really
changed the entire machine learning
field and it caused a revolution in its
own right and so I think it's amazing
for amazingly forward-looking because I
could have imagined and I was an at
Google time but I could imagine the
different contacts and different world
where a company says machine learning is
critical to what we're doing we're not
going to give it to other people
right and so that decision is a profound
a profoundly brilliant insight that I
think has really led to the world being
better and better for Google as well and
has all kinds of ripple effects I think
it is really I mean you can't understate
Google does
adding that how profound that is for
software is awesome well and it's been
in again I can understand the concern
about if we release our machine learning
software are our competitors could go
faster from the other hand I think that
open sourcing test flow has been
fantastic for Google and I'm sure that
obvious was that that that decision was
very non obvious at the time
but I think it's worked out very well so
let's try this real quick yeah you were
at Tesla for five months as the VP of
auto pilot software you led the team
during the transition from each hardware
one hardware to I have a couple
questions so one first of all to me
that's one of the bravest engineering
decisions undertaking
so like undertaking really ever in the
automotive industry to me software wise
starting from scratch it's a really
brave a decision so my one question is
there's always that like what was the
challenge of that do you mean the career
decision of jumping from a comfortable
good job into the unknown or that
combined so the at the individual level
you making that decision and then when
you show up you know it's a really hard
engineering process so you could just
stay maybe slow down say hardware one or
that those kinds of decisions
just taking it full-on let's let's do
this from scratch what was that like
well so I mean I don't think Tesla has a
culture of taking things slow insights
how it goes
and one of the things that attracted me
about Tesla is it's very much a gung-ho
let's change the world let's figure it
out kind of a place and so I have a huge
amount of respect for that
Tesla has done very smart things with
hardware one in particular and the
harder one design was originally
designed to be very simple automation
features in the car for like traffic
aware cruise control and things like
that and the fact that they were able to
effectively feature creep it into lane
holding and and a very useful driver
assistance features is pretty astounding
particularly given the details of the
hardware hardware to built on that a lot
of ways and the challenge there was that
they were transitioning from a third
party provided vision stack to an
in-house built vision stack and so for
the first step which I mostly helped
with was getting onto that new vision
stack and that was very challenging and
there were it was time critical for
various reasons and it was a big leap
but it was fortunate that built on a lot
of the knowledge and expertise and the
team that had built harder ones driver
assistance features so you spoke in a
collected and kind way about your time
at Tesla but it was ultimately not a
good fit Elon Musk we've talked on his
podcast several guests the course he
almost continues to do some of the most
bold and innovative engineering work in
the world
at times at the cost some of the members
of the test the team what did you learn
about this working in this chaotic world
Leon yeah so I guess I would say that
when I was at Tesla I experienced and
saw vert the highest degree of turnover
I'd ever seen in a company my which was
a bit of a shock but one of the things I
learned and I came to respect is that
Elon is able to attract amazing talent
because he has a very clear vision of
the future and he can get people to buy
into it because they want that future to
happen right and the power of vision is
something that I have a tremendous
amount of respect for and I think that
Elon is fairly singular in the world in
terms of the things he's able to get
people to believe in and it's it's a
very it's very there many people who
stay on the street corner and say ah
we're gonna go to Mars right but then
but then there are a few people that can
get other others to buy into it and
believe in build the path and make it
happen and so I respect that
I don't respect all of his methods but
but I have a huge amount of respect for
that you've mentioned in a few places
including in this context working hard
what does it mean to work hard and when
you look back at your life what are what
were some of the most brutal periods of
having to really sort of put everything
you have into something yeah good
question
so working hard can be defined a lot of
different ways so a lot of hours and so
that's that is true the thing to me
that's the hardest is both being
short-term focused on delivering and
executing and making a thing happen
while also thinking about the
longer-term and trying to balance that
right because if you are myopically
focused on solving a task and getting
that done and only think about that
incremental next step you will miss the
next big hill you should jump over -
right and so I've been really fortunate
that I've been able to kind of oscillate
between the two and historically at
Apple for example that was made possible
because I was able to work some really
amazing people and build up teams and
leadership structures and and allow them
to grow in their careers and take on
responsibilities thereby freeing up me
to be a little bit crazy and thinking
about the next thing and so it's it's a
lot of that but it's also about you know
with the experience you make connections
that other people don't necessarily make
and so I think that is that's a big part
as well but the bedrock is just a lot of
hours and you know that's that's okay
with me
there's different theories on work-life
balance and my theory for myself which I
do not project on to the team but my
theory for myself is that you know I I
wanted love what I'm doing and work
really hard and my purpose I feel like
and my goal is to change the world and
make it a better place and that's that's
what I'm really motivated to do so last
question LLVM logo is a dragon
you know you explain that this is
because dragons have connotations of
power speed intelligence it can also be
sleek elegant and
modular till you remove them the modular
part what is your favorite
dragon-related character from fiction
video or movies so those are all very
kind ways of explaining it that you
wanna know the real reason it's a dragon
well yeah so there is a seminal book on
compiler design called the dragon book
and so this is a really old now book on
compilers and so the the dragon logo for
LVM came about because at Apple we kept
talking about LLVM related technologies
and there's no logo to put on a slide
it's sort of like what do we do and
somebody's like well what kind of logo
should a compiler technology have and
I'm like I don't know I mean the Dragons
or the dragon is the best thing that
that we've got and you know Apple
somehow magically came up with the logo
and and it was a great thing and the
whole community rallied around it and
and then it got better as other graphic
designers got involved but that's that's
originally where it came from
story is they're dragons from fiction
that you connect with for that Game of
Thrones
Lord of the Rings that kind of thing
Lord of the Rings is great I also like
role-playing games and things like in
computer role-playing games and so
Dragons often show up in there but but
really comes back to to to the book oh
no we need we need a thing yeah and
hilariously one of the one of the the
funny things about LLVM is that my wife
who's amazing runs the the LVM
foundation and she goes to Grace Hopper
and it's trying to get more women
involved in the she's also compiler
engineer so she's trying to get other
other women to get interested in
compilers and things like this and so
she hands out the stickers and people
like the LVM sticker because a game of
thrones and so sometimes culture has
this whole effect to like get the next
generation if hilar engineers engaged
with the cause okay awesome Chris thanks
so much for time great talking with you
you